rubiny carré est venu défendre ses deux
jeunes femmes parce qu'elles ont le même
gagne-pain et se gagne pas il s'appelle
only fan only fan c'est un site c'est un
site sur lequel on vend des photos de
soi dénudés pour gagner beaucoup
d'argent et en fait ce qui m'exaspère
c'est que les filles comme vous et il y
a aussi des garçons qui le font vous
êtes tellement prête et prêt à tout et
n'importe quoi pour qu'on croit que vous
êtes des gens importants que vous êtes
des stars que vous êtes fortunés que le
seul moyen que vous utilisez pour y
arriver c'est la nudité donc vous vendez
des photos etc et cette nudité dans
votre monde fictif de nifan certes ça
intéresse les gens a essayé de le faire
c'est zéro voilà non mais non mais ça
marche bien sûr non mais très bien il y
a un public pour ça mais là on est dans
la vraie vie on est dans un restaurant
est-ce que dans ce pays c'est la
dictature en fait non mais Ruby
quand je vais prendre un petit déjeuner
à 8h du matin
ton discours est misogyne
ça va pas du tout quand je vais prendre
je vais prendre un petit déjeuner à 8h
du matin je n'ai pas envie d'avoir
quelqu'un à moitié à poil à côté de moi
que ce soit un homme ou une femme pour
elle elle veulent plaire ton seul
argument c'est de crier à la misogyne au
machisme mais c'est toi Ruby qui réduit
moi je pense aussi la liberté il y a un
moment faut arrêter moi je suis en
France ici si j'ai envie d'aller
n'importe quelle heure dans un
restaurant et j'ai envie d'être jolie je
le fais pour moi maintenant c'est à des
hommes qui savent pas se tenir c'est pas
mon problème c'est à dire que
c'est pas possible
[Rires]
on a perdu la 4G
en fait ton seul argument c'est de crier
au machisme et au sexisme mais pardon
c'est toi qui réduit la femme un objet
sexuel à de la provocation sexuelle à
montrer en permanence et elle n'existait
à travers ça et je vais vous dire
pourquoi vous le faites parce que non
pas du tout je veux dire pourquoi vous
le faites parce que vous êtes une
génération qui ne fait aucun effort qui
ne veut pas travailler et votre seul
moyen d'exister et de gagner de l'argent
facilement c'est de se mettre à poil et
on est malheureusement on vit dans un
monde où c'est mieux payé de se poser en
string dans un lit que d'aller bosser et
ça je trouve ça déplorable c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
en France
c'est moi qui te parle c'est Siri
qu'est-ce que tu as quel âge
ments dans l'immobilier